[Music]
imagine going into a mall and printing
up a brand new pair of sneakers or how
about using the creativity of poets and
musicians to power a robot in your home
sound crazy well both are now possible
thanks to some of the most creative
minds working today Wired magazine has
selected 20 visionaries for their annual
next list men and women who are bringing
the future to your doorstep here with
some of the profiles is CBS News
contributor and wired editor-in-chief
Nicholas Thompson Nick a morning more
nanti first of all how did you pick
these folks well we went to all of our
reporters and we said who is the most
interesting person working in your field
who's doing something that really
matters but who we probably haven't
heard of yet came up with a big list
made it a small list all right let's
start with the list so first up is manu
prakash the founder of fold scope
instruments what does he do so what I
love about him is he's taking technology
and bringing it all over the world so he
started with microscopes how could we
make a tiny origami marker scope and now
he's made a tiny centrifuge which is
great for diagnosing diseases very cool
next up are actually three women who all
work at Amazon tell us about them so I
love them because they're the three
women who are behind the voice of Alexa
which is really complicated
how do you create the personality what
kind of jokes should she say how do you
make her appear confident but also tough
so three women all of whom have had some
a certain amount of writing in their
careers I've ever dated that personality
Beth Holmes Farrah Huston and Michelle
Reagan ransom yep all liberal arts
majors comedy of Alexis which matters
it's kitchen it's true she's very
personal yeah the next visionary at
Germany's GERD Mons he is the vice
president of the future team at adidas
what do they do
so adidas is making entirely robot
factories you can have your shoes much
more custom much more built much more
quickly and it's a huge experimentation
in robotic engineering and they're going
very hard at that and he's got that's
why we picked him big implications for
the industry big implications for the
world complicated implications for the
world but from Wired magazine about how
technology is changing the world
absolutely an innovator right next up is
will Marshall co-founder and CEO of a
company called planet so what's
happening right now is there are lots of
big satellites up in the air and they're
huge and expensive and there
controlled by industry they're
controlled by government government and
he's putting up all these little
satellites that can kind of circle the
earth all the time and think about what
that can give you can give you much more
information about deforestation well you
can imagine search-and-rescue operations
it's very helpful to have lots and lots
of satellites up there and have access
to them be you know through a small
company putting up small satellites ah I
like it the trip afterwards pretty neat
Steve Lacey is only 18 years old he's a
musician why is he on the list he's on
the list because he's recording music
for people like Kendrick Lamar just on
his iPhone he just sits there he plays
into his iPhone works on GarageBand
mixes it up together and just part of
some of the most important music being
created and the audio quality is good
enough for an album the audio quality is
good and the music's good that's the
other thing we didn't like his music he
plays he's off the list like a lot of
guys actually oh geez music on the
iPhone but some you're not gonna want to
hear have to be innovative and we have
to like it
right alright next Lily Peng who's using
artificial intelligence to assist
doctors right so one of the things
happening with artificial intelligence
it's got really good first and
recognizing cats on the internet right
this is a cat this is not yeah we need
well that was step one it was a big
breakthrough that's a very important
thing but when you can recognize cats
you can also recognize medical imaging
right and you can look oh you can
recognize retinal scans and you can look
and say oh this person is something
going on with their eyes so the
technology that was used to recognize
this is a cat and this is not a cat is
now being used recognized this is a
disease and this is not a disease that's
why cats are great this is why it's very
important that cats created the Internet
and why we're so glad it would make
dominant is the most popular thing on me
and edwart with good reason okay finally
Leslie Miley he's a West Coast president
adventure for America yep
he wants the Silicon Valley to share its
astronomical wealth with the rest of the
country is that gonna happen what's he
doing well so what he's doing first part
of that quarter that question first what
he's doing he's a former slack engineer
he's trying to set up programs to bring
technology entrepreneurs into the rest
of the country right all of the venture
money all of the expertise is
centralized in San Francisco New York
Boston very small number of pockets of
America he's saying well let's go to
Detroit you know let's get some startups
in
let's get some startups in Baltimore
let's build up there and it would make a
lot of sense it would be good for those
cities and it would be good for Silicon
Valley if it had a much more diverse set
of places where its operating where
people can come up and then also where
the influence and ideas can spread
around the country different products it
is not good for so much of Technology
centered in San Francisco even though
wire is awesome right insularity bad
that's on the internet good yeah you
know what you just put that on the cover
and on the cover of done with that
forget the list in fact next list 2018
best ket we're going to have a guest
editor and here's you and sell sadly it
would Nick Thompson thank you very much
thanks for having me here